>> Hey guys. Grant popping in to remind you
There's only one week left
to get your name on the list
to win the Nintendo Switch and Mario Kart 8.
This is going to one of you.
So, click the link in the description.
Make sure your name is on the list.
See you there.
>> Road flares have
oxidizers mixed in with them,
which means they are supposed
to be able to burn even underwater.
But we wanted to see what would happen
if we burn it,
not just under water,
but also in liquid nitrogen.
[Captions by Judy V. at Y Translator]
[Music]
The basic idea is we'll test
the flare burning underwater
by lighting one and submerging it.
Then we'll move on to submerging
a lit flare in the same container
full of liquid nitrogen.
After that, we'll try putting
a flare down into the liquid nitrogen,
unlit,
letting it freeze solid,
and then see if it will light at that point.
The manufacturer's instructions do say
that these are tested
to burn vertically under water.
But horizontally, the water can put them out.
Our container is pretty much
the right shape for testing a vertical burn,
so I'm hoping it works quite well.
The cap on a flare comes with a striking tab.
It's kind of the side on a box of matches.
This little bead on
the front of the flare
is like the head of a match.
Striking the two together
should ignite the flare.
[Music]
These particular flares are
largely composed of Strontium Nitrate,
Sulfur and Potassium Nitrate.
Those chemicals help
give it the vibrant red color
that we can see here.
Let's see what happens if we take
a flare and submerge it in the water.
Ready?
[Music]
That didn't look so waterproof to me.
Didn't work at all.
[Music]
Where's the T-Rex?
Over here, over here.
[indiscernible screaming]
Alright let's see if it works any better
slightly earlier in its burn.
[Music]
Well it does keep burning,
but it looks like it may start dimming
after it's in there for a couple seconds.
[Music]
Oh no.
Well it's supposed
to stay lit under water,
and we have mixed results with that.
Right near the beginning,
it was pushing out with enough gas
that it seemed to sort of keep burning.
But this one after had been
burning for a couple of minutes,
I tried putting it down to the water,
and it did put it out.
So let's find out if
we get a similar result,
dipping a flare into liquid nitrogen.
[Music]
All right. Here it goes.
Road flare in liquid nitrogen.
[Music]
Ah, our glass container.
Well,
I didn't see that coming.
I guess maybe I should have,
but I didn't.
A little bit of burning flare
landed on the screen of my phone just now.
And I now have a lovely dead spot on my screen.
[Music]
Well, it's still looks
like it's burning to me.
It is discoloring
the liquid nitrogen somehow.
[Music]
I think its definitely making
the liquid nitrogen boil away faster.
[Music]
Still burning.
Back in.
[Music]
I don't think it puts it out.
We've got one more thing we want to try.
And that's to freeze a road flare
and then see what happens
when we try and light it.
All right.
Unlit road flare going
into our liquid nitrogen.
[Music]
The liquid nitrogen already in the cup
has been discolored by
the flare that was dipped in it before.
Normally of course, it's completely clear.
But there have been some pollutants
from a road flare that have stained it,
sort of a dark greenish color.
This is like swamp liquid nitrogen now.
Our flares now been sitting
in the liquid nitrogen
for four or five minutes.
So I'm going to say it is good and frozen,
at least where I'm going to be lighting it.
[Music]
It looks the same.
Let's see if it lights the same.
[Music]
There it goes.
Well, it was definitely
harder to get it to light.
And so far, I think this has
got a little less burning power
than it did when it wasn't frozen.
Of course, as it burns,
it warms itself back up.
And so it may not be
a very long lasting effect.
It definitely was harder
to get it started though.
Still burning.
Can't deny that.
[Music]
Guys, there's still more for you to see.
That little box up at the top
will transport you
directly to our last video.
Go check it out.
The box at the bottom
will show you what YouTube thinks
you should be watching next.
And this bomb here in the center
will subscribe to the channel,
so you never miss another video.
Don't forget to ring that bell.
And we'll see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.